You're going to use Android Studio
to create the DetailActivity
from the Blank Activity
with Fragment template.
The template asks for the
hierarchical parent of DetailActivity,
which defines the UP button
noted by the app icon,
and a left-pointing carat here.
But what does "up" mean?
If you mapped out a hierarchy
of all screens in the Sunshine app,
the root of the tree
would be the MainActivity,
and it's child would be
the DetailActivity.
So, the UP goes to the MainActivity.
While the BACK button
can achieve the same effect,
it can also bring you back home,
or to another app,
depending on your history of screens.
UP will always navigate you
within the same app to the parent,
regardless of how
you arrived at this screen.
Create the detail activity now,
and look at how the activity is declared
in the Android manifest file.